[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend les corresponds
sur Public Sénat aujourd'hui on vous
parle de ces vents contraires que subit
actuellement nos entreprises entre la
crise énergétique la remontée des tôles
intérêts ou encore la menace de
récession tout est réuni pour les mettre
en difficulté à commencer par ses
factures d'électricité qui étrangle de
plus en plus de PME reportage à suivre
dans quelques instants Nicolas Dufourcq
le patron de BPI France sera notre
invité spéciale et nous dira comment les
entreprises peuvent résister et garder
le cap dans cette tempête mais d'abord
direction l'Alsace chez un producteur de
briques et de tuiles dont la facture
énergétique a flambé dans les
proportions phénoménales manuel lagre
nous avons rendez-vous chez vinerberger
le leader de la terre cuite ici dans
leur usine près de Strasbourg sortent
chaque année 150 000 tonnes de briques
mais depuis quelques mois bien que le
carnet de commandes soit rempli
l'entreprise n'est pas sereine
on vient récupérer cet argile et ensuite
on va broyer cette matière première la
façonner la sécher la cuire pour avoir
une brique finie avant que ça parte
circuit
autant d'étapes qui pèse chaque jour un
peu plus sur l'entreprise alors jusque
là sur les deux premières
c'est l'équivalent de la consommation
électrique de 850 petits logements
c'est le gaz naturel qui est utilisé ici
et pour cause l'entreprise dispose d'un
four de 180 mètres de long atteignant
les 900 degrés
on va sortir plus de 25 tonnes de
produits par heure la montée en
température d'un four froid peut prendre
plusieurs jours jusqu'à 5 jours chez
nous donc il faut bien comprendre que
c'est pas un système on off on va pas
couper le four pour leur démarrer une
heure après l'idée c'est quand il est
lancé chez nous nos période d'activité
sont de plus de 18 mois une entreprise
énergievort qui n'a à ce jour aucune
autre solution pour produire de la
brique en terre cuite on peut observer
une augmentation du gaz de X 10
quasiment depuis depuis quelques mois et
quasiment de x 20 sur l'électricité donc
si on prend un exemple concret nos
produits entre
2000-2020 et aujourd'hui les produits
ont été augmentés de 25%, une
augmentation du prix de vente et une
marge rabotée alors pour sauver
l'entreprise Frédéric doit prendre des
mesures d'urgence on est vraiment dans
l'obligation d'aller chercher chaque
perte d'énergie d'entreprise à travers
une équipe dédiée dans le lit management
pour aller chercher vraiment chaque
gâchis d'énergie et donc vraiment ça
c'est extrêmement important c'est la
première action c'est la sobriété mais
pour que son entreprise prospère
sereinement Frédéric doit aller au-delà
anticiper à long terme les pénuries et
coûts de l'énergie en chaque crise une
opportunité en particulier sur
l'autonomie énergétique on va déployer
des technologies de transformation dans
le monde du gaz mais également excité en
installant des panneaux photovoltaïques
en utilisant de la géothermie en
utilisant déjà aujourd'hui 100%
d'électricité d'énergie décarbonée est
verte et là aujourd'hui on va accélérer
aussi la l'alternative de d'usage de
gain naturel par du gaz de synthèse et
de la biomasse en grande masse c'est le
cas de le dire
changer d'énergie être autonome Frédéric
se lance dans une transformation
onéreuse qui pour lui serait la clé pour
pérenniser son activité
mais aujourd'hui toutes les entreprises
ne peuvent pas se le permettre
cet environ 150 000 entreprises qui
seraient concernées par l'augmentation
du coût de l'énergie aujourd'hui et à
partir du 1er janvier 2023 autant vous
dire que nous sommes face
potentiellement à risque systémique si
l'entreprise est obligée de baisser le
rideau de réduire la voilure à cause du
coût d'énergie bien évidemment il y a un
impact sur les salariés quand vous
arrêtez votre activité et bien si les
licenciement lorsque vous réduisez la
voilure et bien c'est peut-être des
heures supplémentaires qui ne se font
plus ou tout simplement des intérimaires
que on ne recrute plus et en tout cas un
gel entre guillemets des embauches donc
oui il y aura un impact alors pour
éviter le pire conserver des emplois
tout en réduisant les charges qui pèsent
sur les entreprises les dirigeants
revoient leur mode de fonctionnement
certaines ont pris des positions
effectivement assez radicales changer
complètement l'organisation du travail
travailler la nuit voilà en heure creuse
par rapport au jour mettre en place de
la production électrique à partir de
générateur qui fonctionne
malheureusement avec avec du gasoil des
solutions peu pérennes mais l'état vient
d'annoncer une aide d'urgence aux
entreprises pour en bénéficier plus
besoin de multiplier les demandes auprès
des différents organismes les démarches
sont simplifiées à travers un guichet
unique les entreprises qui ont vu leur
facture d'électricité ou de gaz augmenté
de plus de 50% par rapport à 2021
pourront compter sur un coup de pouce de
l'État mais pour François Asselin ce
geste reste insuffisant lorsque vous
avez une facture qui passe de 80 000
euros à un million d'euros combien même
on vous en rabote 28% vous allez payer
720 000 euros ça sera pas suffisant pour
pouvoir continuer à produire nous ce que
nous demandons ce qu'il y ait un guichet
qui soit créé en dernier recours voilà
avant qu'une entreprise baisse le rideau
franchement elles ne sont pour rien
responsables de cette crise que nous
subissons l'énergie et bien faire en
sorte que et bien on regarde une façon
rapide efficace quels sont les moyens
qu'on peut appliquer manière vraiment
discrétionnaire très direct individuel à
cette entreprise qui ne peut pas s'en
sortir à cause du coût de l'énergie
[Musique]
certaines entreprises ont d'ores et déjà
déclaré qu'elle n'hésiteraient pas à
quitter la France pour réimplanter leur
industrie à l'étranger là où le coût de
l'énergie est plus faible
[Musique]
crise énergétique remontée des taux
d'intérêt menaces de récession comment
garder le cap et aussi le moral quand on
dirige une entreprise aujourd'hui notre
invité spéciale c'est vous Nicolas
dufourk bonjour bonjour directeur
général de BPI France alors on vient de
le voir d'endroit reportage cette PME
alsacienne qui a vu sa facture
énergétique multipliée par plus de 4
évidemment elle n'est pas la seule
d'ailleurs on a vu le Medef tirer le
signal d'alarme est-ce que vous aussi
pour nos PME industrielles vous êtes
inquiets
on est nombreux à avoir tiré le signal
d'alarme depuis le mois de juillet
sachant que le gouvernement faisant ses
comptes en septembre-octobre a fini par
sortir il y a une petite mort il y a
trois semaines un dispositif important
qui représente plus d'une dizaine de
milliards d'euros de dépenses publiques
aujourd'hui ça a l'air de rien 10
milliards d'euros mais il y a quelques
années ça aurait été un plan gigantesque
et ce plan je ne sais pas si cette
société le compte dans la multiplication
par 4
énergétique probablement mais c'est un
plan qui est particulièrement généreux
que je peux détailler d'ailleurs si vous
le souhaitez mais mais tous ceux qui me
regardent je les incite à se rapprocher
des services
fiscaux de leur département puisque
c'est un guichet c'est un nouveau
guichet c'est un ancien fonctionnait pas
bien il a été l'ancien fonctionnait pas
bien on l'appelait Ukraine il faut que
c'est pas bien parce que les critères
qui avaient été imposés en réalité par
la Direction Générale de la Concurrence
de Bruxelles ça fait beaucoup trop
restrictif et donc personne en fait
n'était dans ce filet il a fallu
plusieurs mois pour renégocier ces
critères et les nouveaux critères sont
beaucoup plus favorables après la
facture pour l'ensemble des entreprises
cette facture énergétique ce sera 16
milliards d'euros nous a dit Medef pour
2022 est-ce que il y a assez d'argent
public encore une fois 10 ou 13
milliards d'euros face à cette flambée
je pense que aujourd'hui il y a une
douzaine de milliards d'euros on va voir
si ça suffit ce qui remonte en tout cas
du portefeuille de bébé France puisque
comme vous savez on est investi dans
1000 entreprises en direct et à peu près
5000 autres entreprises au travers des
fonds que nous finançons donc on a quand
même un échantillon tophédi sans parler
des entreprises auxquelles nous faisons
crédit c'est que pour l'instant ça passe
pour l'instant ça passe donc on a pas
les nouveaux tarifs vont arriver en 2023
c'est peut-être là on verra à la réalité
non alors par ailleurs par ailleurs ce
qu'il faut comprendre en effet c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les tables d'électricité
sont les tarifs à terme sur un marché
qui est un marché irrationnel tu as
marché qui anticipe que les centrales
nucléaires ne vont pas repartir que en
revanche la guerre en Ukraine va
redoubler que etc donc les prix à terme
de l'électricité si vous interrogez la
Commission de régulation d'électricité
ou si vous interrogez RTE notre grand
réseau de distribution d'électricité
français sont totalement irrationnelles
donc je pense que comme les entrains le
client française vont repartir c'est le
mois de janvier ça ira mieux on va y
aller et je pense par ailleurs que le
marché va se calmer donc je pense mais
ça n'est que moi mais après tout on est
là pour livrer ces intuitions qu'à la
fin de 2023 on va retrouver un marché
d'électricité qui sera un marché
beaucoup plus raisonnable donc pas
besoin de mettre en place un bouclier un
bouclier tarifaire pour les entreprises
le bouclier l'an prochain il existe
jusqu'à la fin 203 ce qui était annoncé
par le gouvernement c'est jusqu'à la fin
2023 donc il y a un guichet fin 2022 qui
va se poursuivre jusqu'à fin 2023 pour
les PME et pour les ETI pardon et pour
les PME un dispositif qui s'appelle
l'amortisseur qui est un dispositif
automatique un peu compliqué mais que
vous trouverez sur tous les sites
internet
va permettre de baisser de l'ordre de
120 euros le mégawatt
la facture d'électricité des PME
françaises pendant toute l'année 2023
bon on a un contexte économique et Nica
Dufour que qui n'est pas facile et c'est
un euphémisme et quand on voit le moral
des patrons et là c'est intéressant
irrésistent c'est ce que nous dit
l'Insee qui mesure tous les mois ce
qu'on appelle le climat des affaires
comment on explique cette résilience et
ce que au niveau du terrain vous-même
chez BPI France vous avez même remontés
absolument et c'est l'enquête que nous
avons publié à trois semaines qui
l’enquête que nous faisons régulièrement
avec Rex et code sur le TPE on fait
également une enquête ETI qu'est-ce
qu'elle montre cette enquête elle montre
que bon le bras n'est quand même pas
stable le moral décline un peu alors
est-ce que c'est le moral c'est
simplement les anticipations
d'investissement aujourd'hui
vous avez
quatre points de moins qu'il y a un
trimestre d'entrepreneurs qui disent
avoir ou vouloir investir en 2022 il est
vrai qu'on se rapproche de la fin
d'année 2022 quoi qu'il arrive donc
grosso modo en 2022 vous aurez un
entrepreneur sur deux qui aura investi
et on s'attendait à ce qui est 55 %.
voilà la différence on passe de 55 à 50
grosso modo donc c'est pas majeur
honnêtement ça veut dire que les
entrepreneurs français sont de plus en
plus résiliens ils sont le plus de plus
en plus résilient pourquoi parce que un
leur carnet de commandes sont très bons
l'économie va bien la consommation tient
européenne en temps le mot récession par
tout imminente menace de récession et là
on parle de quand même commande qui aime
bien parce que je pense que voilà donc
on est
on se rapproche de la fin d'année on va
se dire qu'en regardant l'automne 2022
derrière nous là il y a eu un mouvement
de catastrophisme ambiant qui était lié
d'ailleurs au fait que la guerre était
imprévisible c'était l'époque où Poutine
parlait d'attaque nucléaire faut sauver
donc il y avait des raisons il y avait
des raisons d'être inquiets tout ça est
déjà un peu passé honnêtement et donc
[Musique]
l'économie française a tenu cette charge
cette charge émotionnelle très très
forte des mois de septembre et octobre
elle a vraiment tenu donc on va vers
quoi maintenant on va vers d'après
l'INSEE et c'est tout à fait ce que nous
anticipons chez BPI France deux
trimestres de très légères récession
moins 0, quelque chose et ensuite deux
trimestres qui vont reprendre de sorte
que à la fin d'année 2023 au total sur
l'année 2023 pour l'instant c'est ce
qu'on voit une légère croissance donc il
y a un trou d'air sur les deux prochains
trimestres il y a un trou d'air sur deux
projets trimestres qui est
essentiellement lié à la crise de
l'énergie il faut se le dire avec le
principal impact qu'on voit aujourd'hui
il y a cette flambée des prix d'énergie
et à ce ralentissement qui est quand
même là c'est l'investissement on voit
des investissements qui ne sont pas
annulés mais qui sont décalé il y a le
cas de ça prend moi qui m'a marqué de
voir sa Franck qui met sur pause pendant
12 18 24 mois un gros projet d'usine de
frein carbone du goûter Lyon à cause du
coût de l'énergie
n'a pas pris la décision d'abandonner
son projet de confiance et de construire
aux US il a juste reporté bon et
[Musique]
là pour lequel s'affront au fond a fait
son report c'est pas simplement la crise
de l'électricité en Europe c'est le
contrat entre la crise de l'électricité
en Europe et les prix d'énergie
extraordinairement bas des États-Unis
c'est ce contraste là qui pose problème
un certain nombre d'industriels qui sont
électro-intensifs notamment les
activités de carbone de safran mais on
pourrait parler de la chimie également
et en particulier la chimie allemande on
va parler juste après de ce plan XXL de
subvention massive je confirme qu'il y a
des reports voilà c'est ça
la première étape souvent le report mais
nous voyons pas le pire un petit mot
juste de la tension est-ce qu'attention
ou pas sur la trésorerie des entreprises
au travers de tout ce qu'on a dit
flamber encore une fois la facture
énergétique ralentissement je ne dirais
pas qu'il y a de tension il y a eu
trésori à bondante fin 2021 parce que
l'année 2021 était la plus belle l'année
macroéconomique que la France est connue
depuis 30 ans qui fait suite à 2026 et
fait 400 euros mais l'effet catapulte
qui a produit énormément de cash et il y
a beaucoup d'argent public aussi et tout
ça surtout dans la trésorerie des
entreprises et puis prenez sommet 2022
idem je connais pas un entrepreneur qui
ne disent de mes premiers 2022 canon
donc on est arrivé à l'été 2022 avec
beaucoup de trésorerie et c'est
trésorerie en effet à l'automne 2022
elle est revenue à son niveau normatif
avant donc oui elle a baissé mais elle
est juste revenue à son niveau dans ma
natif d'avant la demande de crédit très
forte
la concurrence entre les banques est
très forte malgré la remontée on en
parlera après des tôles intérêts malgré
leur montée taux d'intérêt et les taux
de sinistralité sont dérisoires fin 2022
les demandes de garantie sur des PG non
remboursés sont très très faibles et je
vais être garantie par l'État
et donc voilà voilà le paysage en effet
étonnant de la fin 2022 où on a eu très
peur mais l'économie tient la Financière
les infrastructures de financement
l'économie sont là et la sinistralité
faible mais l'impact le gros de l'impact
sera priori début 202300 on l'a compris
et certains voudraient croire que ce
choc énergétique est passager on
aimerait bien évidemment ce soit le cas
on a aussi des qui nous dit le contraire
que cette crise énergétique est là pour
durer bon après c'est leur point de vue
vous me direz mais ce qu'il faut s'y
préparer est-ce que ça la question
est-ce qu'on est préparé peut-être à une
nouvelle donne en matière de coût de
l'énergie qui se resterait à niveau
élevé alors c'est très difficile
d'anticiper ce qui va se passer est-ce
qu'on reviendra au coup au prix donc de
l'énergie d'avant il y avait un gaz
russe extraordinaire abondant qui
permettait de guider des prix
d'électricité extrêmement faibles
parenthèses plus faible que les coûts de
production du nucléaire probablement pas
est-ce qu'on aura donc une énergie
européenne qui sera compétitive par
rapport à l'énergie américaine
probablement pas compétitif par rapport
à l'énergie chin oui donc il y a un
sujet d'extrême compétitivité l'énergie
américaine
est-ce qu'on peut continuer de
développer une industrie européenne avec
une énergie un peu plus cher j'ai pas
dit massivement plus cher mais un peu
plus cher je pense que oui ça dépend
on met le curseur exactement c'est clair
que si on stabilise dans la durée à 180
euros le mégawatt c'est quand même un
choc pétrolier puisque ça fait trois
fois plus qu'avant donc il y a des il y
a des électro intensifs qui nous plaît
une partie de l'aluminium etc et
d'ailleurs cette crise énergétique
provoque une un grave problème de
compétitivité c'est ce que nous a
rappelé Geoffroy route des yeux le
patron du Medef d'ailleurs on a eu
président de la République qui récemment
a reçu l'ensemble des industriels enfin
les plus gros européens pour les inciter
à rester en France et en Europe c'est
vrai que cette crise énergétique va
peut-être pousser beaucoup d'entreprises
industrielles notamment hors de France à
investir hors de France on pense
notamment aux États-Unis oui
alors ça dépend des secteurs de
l'industrie mais il y en a qui sont plus
ou moins consommateurs d'énergie il y en
a qui peuvent très bien tenir avec une
énergie un peu plus chère il y en a pour
lequel c'est en effet tout à fait
critique donc ça c'est simple si on veut
garder ses industries là qui sont celles
que vous avez cité tout à l'heure on
peut parler de la France mais je pense
surtout à l'Allemagne parce que c'est
l'Allemagne et c'est l'Europe de l'Est
qui sont ultra chargés en activité
industrielle électro-intensive il faudra
de la subvention publique et c'est ça
qui c'est ça qui va être débattu dans
dans les mois qui nous séparent de la
fin 2023 parce qu'aux États-Unis faut le
rappeler Nicolas dufourc l'énergie on se
rend pas compte mais trois fois quatre
fois cinq fois moins cher qu'en France
et qu'en Europe donc on n'est pas armes
égales aujourd'hui en matière d'accès au
prix de l'énergie allemande un problème
tout le secteur de l'acier un problème
l'aluminium un problème la verrerie on
est actuellement de verre alia donc je
suis pas forcément extrêmement fier de
vous dire même si j'aime beaucoup vers
aliens que Verallia ne dépend pas
d'électricité puisque Verallia c'est du
fioul
donc il se trouve que les prix du vieux
sont faibles aujourd'hui puisque le
gazelle enfin bref pétrole gaz tout ça
plutôt bien baissé donc la verrerie
n'est pas n'est pas n'est pas propre en
parler touché cette ville-là
notre ami Saladin a fait une tribune
avec Louis Galois ce matin dans Les
Echos c'est sûr que pour ça commence
c'est compliqué donc on va on va devoir
traiter ce problème en 2000 en 2023
c'est tout à fait clair avec un risque
une vague possible de
désindustrialisation encore une fois
pardon le mot est choquant mais c'est ce
qui alors qu'on avait commencé un petit
peu à rien industrialiser une prise de
conscience de l'argent public une
volonté qui peut-être se fracasse sur
cette crise énergétique si elle devait
durer ça c'est sûr que par rapport à aux
espérances du premier semestre et de
l'été 2022 après tant d'années
bien
c'est un peu le coup trois quoi c'est un
peu le coup de froid et et est-ce que
est-ce que ça condamne finalement
l'Europe a redémarré une phase de
désindustrialisation personnellement je
ne le pense pas parce que l'Europe ne
l'acceptera pas tout simplement parce
que l'Europe qui est quand même un
gigantesque conflit industriel
aujourd'hui qui a beaucoup souffert donc
plein de pays et particulièrement la
France de sa des industrialisation ne
veut pas ressouffrir et en même temps il
veut pas retraverser ce qu'il a déjà ce
plan des Joe Biden qui a dégainé son
hiéral rendu une flèche en anglais des
subventions colossales plusieurs
centaines de milliards de dollars pour
financer des investissements industriels
vers je rappelle 7500 dollars d'aide
pour tout achat d'une voiture électrique
produites sur l'Amérique vous me direz
en France on a des aides mais elles sont
pour tout les véhicules quel que soit
leur lieu de production est-ce que
l'Europe voilà l'Europe ne doit pas
rester les bras ballants on doit
favoriser aussi notre industrie locale
bien sûr mais c'est ce qui va se passer
ne restera pas les bras ballants
mais c'est ce qui va se passer parce que
ce que ce que ce que le Congrès
américain a voté finalement
l'indication d'un changement radical
d'époque ou puisque les Chinois l'ont
fait les Américains vont le faire et les
Américains nous disent vous les
européens ou vous empêchera pas de le
faire on comprendrait que vous fassiez
comme nous ils viennent de le dire donc
ils l'ont dit il y a trois semaines
qu'en président de la République était
aux États-Unis donc
c'est
évidemment des choses qui vont être
discutées maintenant alors donc c'est un
nouveau monde on a les moyens pardon
parce que aussi il faut avoir des moyens
publics financiers alors s'aligner
encore une fois sur les standards de
subventions XXL américain bien
on va dire que certains pays ont les
moyens oui les pays européens ont les
moyens l'Allemagne est un moyen la
France moins
mais mais c'est le finalement c'est le
paradoxe de la désindustrialisation
française c'est que on a moins à
protéger
quand vous voulez protéger tout le tissu
industriel allemand là il va falloir de
gros moyens il se trouve que les
Allemands les ont ils ont un deux fois
plus important rapporté au PIB que nous
ou de mouillés
après il y a aussi ce cavalier seul
allemand on a pu en parler juste avant
avec son plan de 100 milliards d'euros
pour soutenir les entreprises face à
cette crise de l'énergie et là on se dit
bon déjà est-ce que c'est très
coopératif on peut on peut en discuter à
côté nous on met 10 fois moins
c'est pas sur une année évidemment mais
quand même
il y avait joué des carottes dans les
200 milliards et par ailleurs les 200
milliards sont encore validés par
Bruxelles c'est parce que Bruxelles a
validé dans les 10 milliards français
annoncés comme je le disais il y a un
mois
ça dit les règles qui vont devoir
s'appliquer aux Allemands aussi mais les
3 % de chiffre d'affaires les 50 %
d'augmentation etc est-ce que ça fait
200 milliards je ne pense pas bon par
ailleurs ce qu'on compte pas dans le
dispositif français tout est un peu
technique pour nous nos auditeurs mais
c'est la reine la reine c'est-à-dire ce
dispositif subventionnel qui permet à
EDF de vendre de l'électricité nucléaire
un tarif extrêmement faible à des
distributeurs qui vont pouvoir
faire de la marge sur cette électricité
là et développer un marché concurrentiel
de l'électricité en France voilà donc le
tarif de la reine il est à de mémoire 80
euros c'est un tarif qui est
subventionnelle et il est subventionnel
et donc votre idée c'est quoi derrière
et que donc ça a un coup et ce coup-là
il faut le rajouter ou dire que j'ai les
Allemands nous disent vous êtes gentil
de dire que 200 milliards c'est trop
mais vous dans ce que vous avez annoncé
vous comptez pas ce que vous coûte la
reine
d’ailleurs au finance publique je la
reine c'est certainement plusieurs
dizaines de milliards je crois 80
milliards
face à tout ça et pour lutter contre
cette spirale inflationniste on change
de sujet mais quand même c'est lié c'est
cette banque centrale européenne qui
remonte rapidement c'est tôle intérêt et
là c'est le thème de l'émission Les
vents contraires que subissent nos
entreprises il y a ce choc énergétique
il y a aussi et c'est un intérêt qui
remonte et on dit évidemment que c'est
pas très bon et c'est pas de bonne
augure pour les boîtes qui qui veulent
investir ça coûte cher d'investir ou qui
doivent se refinancer ou qui sont très
endettés et parfois c'est lié
ça c'est sûr que la Banque centrale
européenne souhaite aller dans son rôle
mais ça fait encore une fois un bon
contrat de plus c'est un bon contrat de
plus mais il faut qu'elle réussisse il
faut il faut il faut qu'on tue cette
inflation
donc il y a pas d'autres solutions
d'être solidaire de cette politique là
il faut qu'on revienne à 3% plus
d'inflation à la fin 2023 parce que
sinon ensuite on est dans des désordres
économiques qui deviennent beaucoup
beaucoup plus coûteux bon donc le sujet
c'est est-ce que les taux d'intérêt vont
rester durablement à ce niveau là c'est
à dire pendant de nombreuses années de
sorte que quantité de temps de
financement deviennent deviennent
influençablement elle était ça c'est une
question qui est encore ouverte plus
rapidement on aura on aura tapé cette
inflation plus cette question plus on
pourra imaginer
notamment le financement de la
transition énergétique qui a coûté
évidemment très très cher comment face à
tous ces vents contraires on les a cité
un remonter rapide taux d'intérêt
tension sur les approvisionnements on en
parle pas mais on sait que c'est aussi
compliqué même si elle était un petit
peu moins pour les employeurs à
l'échelle d'entreprise cette inflation
qui est galopante et qui doit être
cassée par les banques centrales
justement les chefs d'entreprise peuvent
garder le cap c'est pas facile et le
moral et rester positif dans cette
tempête
vous qui les grâce à l'innovation en
réalité c'est à dire que si vous savez
c'est un coup si l'innovation c'est un
coup oui tout n'a d'ailleurs pas
forcément un coup gigantesque mais le
simple fait que vous
soyez féconds tout simplement avec des
nouveaux produits des nouvelles techno
des nouveaux brevets donc une projection
vers l'avenir et fait que
par le mix qualité prix de vos produits
vous pouvez absorber des chocs c'est sûr
que si vous continuez de vendre ce que
vous vendiez en 2018
ça peut mal se terminer voilà donc et
c'est là qu'on trouve le mandat de BPI
France au coeur c'est que c'est que
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait France 2030
54 milliards d'euros aujourd'hui sur les
54 milliards on a déjà déployé nous et
puis les autres opérateurs sur la
première année de France 2030 on aura
déployé à peu près 10 milliards d'euros
quand même et sur les 10 milliards PPI
France 8 milliards en un an uniquement
pour financer l'innovation donc c'est
c'est pour moi la grande solution
après il faut renouvellement de l'offre
et pour ça il faut aussi des
entrepreneurs il faut oser il faut il
faut voilà il faut oser entreprendre
prendre des risques
mais pas tout le monde la lame de
l'entrepreneur non plus
oui alors il y a quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de Français qui ont cette fibre
là beaucoup beaucoup pour peu que c'est
vos questions absolument pour peu que il
sache lutter contre leur propre peur
et là le rôle de la BPI aussi c'est de
dire à tout le monde attendez on est là
on est là carrément avec une boîte à
outils incroyable la beauté aussi les
plus profondes du monde et puis il y a
pas que nous c'est à dire que vous avez
la santé gratuite l'éducation gratuite
les infrastructures etc donc vous êtes
dans un pays dans lequel quantité de
risque non couverts à l'étranger sont
couverts par la société française et
donc vous pouvez être entrepreneur si
vous en rêvez mais allez-y j'attends
qu'il faut ce modèle social qui est
généreux qui est très bien comme ça il
faut pour le pérenniser il faut il faut
plus de plus d'entreprises plus
d'activités plus plus plus quoi non mais
absolument mais je pense d'ailleurs que
les Français sont prêts à ce qu'on dise
cela et qu'on exprime au fond cette
vérité qui est que dans un pays
ultra protecteur on peut être ult
entrepreneur et que l'un ne va pas sans
l'autre
il faut être ultra entrepreneur pour
financer le modèle social et parce qu'on
peut être ultra- entrepreneur donc tous
ceux qui nous regardent aujourd'hui et
qui se disent qui se réveille le matin à
6h dans le demi-sommeil et en se disant
je suis peut-être en train de passer à
côté de ma vie
ils sont nombreux je pense en France il
faut leur dire pas de problème
lancez-vous
et vous avez cette conviction que la
France a un potentiel inexploité ça je
le sais je vous connais oui ah oui non
ça j'en suis absolument convaincu la
France il faut faire monter sa
température à haut niveau hein grosse
température et là elle est capable de
choses extraordinaire merci pour cet
entretien Nicole dufourc directeur
général de BB France rappel votre livre
la désindustrialisation de la France
chez Odile Jacob qui n'est pas une
fatalité la crise énergétique nous aide
pas mais le combat n'est pas perdu
d'avance je veux qu'on finisse sur une
autre positive aucun combat n'est perdu
avant et quand on est compatible en
général on gagne allez merci à vous
merci c'est la fin de pourvu que ça dure
l'émission qui rend les co-responsables
sur Public Sénat émission à voir ou
revoir sur Public Sénat le repas bien
sûr vous le savez c'est public c'est la
foret faire on se retrouve dans deux
semaines
[Musique]